it's been  2190 days Rihanna we waited it's been  over six years  Rihanna's making her return after years  away from performing the singer will be  hitting the stage at the Apple music  Super Bowl 52 halftime show and apple  music dropped a teaser for the events  the fans just predicted  now this isn't the first time Rihanna  has performed at halftime as she Drake  and Kanye West were the acts at the 2011  NBA All-Star Game  Lift Me Up  [Music]  Super Bowl 52 takes place Sunday  February 12th from State Farm stadium in  Glendale Arizona now this will be the  first ever halftime show presented by  Apple music no word yet on what hits  Rihanna will be performing or if she  could surprise us with something new but  fingers crossed from umbrella right  you please